so you're a starving artist in need of
some serious cash or maybe you're a
photoshop pro and freelancing gigs just
aren't cutting it anymore
well you're in luck because your
specific skill set makes you the perfect
person for one of the world's most
sophisticated crimes
counterfeiting
sure you can steal art or jewelry or
even rob a bank but why jump through all
those hoops to get your hands on cold
hard cash when you could just print the
money yourself the federal reserve
prints money every day what's a few more
dollars thrown into the mix gonna do
anyone can steal stuff but making money
is an art
it takes finesse sophistication way
above the common everyday criminal so
becoming a career counterfeiter is
obviously the only logical route
but just like any other crime the bigger
your operation the bigger the punishment
if you get caught
counterfeiting money takes skill
patience and lots of planning
one mistake and you're screwed it's the
reason why there are so few
counterfeiters left in the world but for
someone of your caliber of skill and
your sheer desperation for cash while
counterfeiting may just be your most
lucrative career ever
so let's learn how to counterfeit money
theoretically of course this is for
entertainment purposes only please don't
counterfeit money
[Music]
i'm not gonna beat around the bush here
counterfeiting is hard
to get anywhere close to the point where
a 100 note you printed passes for the
real thing even under dim lights in a
busy bar you're going to need a lot of
information
up until 1861 counterfeiting was
extremely easy there was no standard
dollar and every regional bank printed
their own version of money around 1850
there were more than 10 000 different
notes in circulation so to counterfeit
money you could literally walk into any
shop with some monopoly money and tell
them you got it from the bank down the
street but then the government took over
the money printer and the design of
money became standardized and regulated
suddenly it was a lot harder to make
good fake money
counterfeiting is so tricky that only
about 0.1 percent of the cash in
existence today is fake compared to
almost half after the civil war today
bills have dozens of markers and unique
characteristics that can be checked to
spot a fake newly printed bills have
color shifting ink watermarks a security
thread that glows a different color
under uv light depending on the value of
the notes which makes counterfeiting
money today about as hard as it is to
fake a piece of fine arts
one missing line the cash not having the
right feel or the security threat
doesn't go exactly as it should and you
are done for
taking all of this into account if you
can choose which bills to counterfeit
going for the ones printed before 1996
is your best choice
they have fewer safeguards which make
them much easier to forge you'll still
have to focus on the blue and red
threads woven into the money fabric the
watermark and a flawless design but at
least you don't have to worry about the
uv glow
so once you know your product inside and
out and you have a clear idea of how to
counterfeit it it's time to look for a
workplace
the biggest counterfeiter out there is
the united states money printer also
known as the federal reserve where every
day they're printing more and more
dollars that come out of your pockets in
reality this is called theft on a wide
scale but they like to use the vague
made up term quantitative easing that's
what crypto tries to solve and if you
want some free bitcoin you can earn up
to 250 for funding your account on block
fi this is not financial advice but i've
already personally made 564 dollars and
74 cents and pure interest just by
keeping my crypto in my block fight
interest accounts i literally did
nothing to make this passive income
that's because block fight is one of the
easiest places to store your crypto
while at the same time earning up to 9
apy on the crypto you keep in your
accounts interest accrues daily and is
paid monthly there are no hidden fees no
minimum balances and no reason to wait
all you have to do is click the link
below open up your blog fi accounts fund
your accounts and you can get up to 250
in free bitcoin as a bonus for signing
up from there the platform allows you to
buy crypto instantly and directly from
your bank accounts and you can also set
up recurring purchases so you can dollar
cost average into crypto which is what i
have set up and you don't have to wait
to see your purchases reflected in your
blockchain accounts and you can get
started with as little as 20
so get your free bitcoin now by pausing
the video and going to blockfy.com jake
with the link below that's blockfy.com
jake with the link in the video
description below thanks to block five
for sponsoring this video
the u.s secret service is in charge of
finding people who try to counterfeit
money and they know exactly what type of
equipment you need which means in most
of the us and europe the printers inc
and other materials commonly used to
make fake money are all on the watch
list buy them and you're probably going
to be on that watch list so when it
comes to counterfeiting you may need to
take your operations overseas choose a
country that's close enough to the us so
you can easily smuggle the dollars in
once they're printed but also choose a
country that has really bad
infrastructure and a corrupt police
force this way you give yourself the
best chance to buy whatever you need
without attracting suspicion once you've
chosen your country your best option for
a workspace is somewhere rural a barn
warehouse or old factory are all great
options as long as you're not
trespassing to avoid drawing attention
the best printers for counterfeiting can
be pretty noisy so choose a spot far
away from other houses
once you've found the perfect location
you're ready to find your crew and
gather your equipment
[Music]
to print money here's what you'll need a
printer obviously ideally you will want
to go with an italian printer which is
what real dollars are printed with
unfortunately they're super expensive
and almost impossible to find unless
you're in north korea who actually
managed to get their hands on one and
started printing almost exact copies of
the dollars called super notes but you
probably don't have the option so the
next best thing is called an offset
printer almost like an intaglio printer
an offset printer transfers ink from a
metal plate to a rubber sheet and then
onto the paper
next you're gonna need paper and not
just any paper the unique 75 to 25 ratio
of cotton to lennon is the real reason
why money feels the way it does any good
counterfeiter will tell you that the
texture size and weight of the money is
what usually gives it away
the paper dollars are printed on also
have red and blue threads woven into
them at random if you can't replicate
this or buy it from the only
manufacturer in the world called crane
your next best bet would be to bleach
existing money and print over it in
south america some great counterfeiters
use venezuelan banknotes which thanks to
hyperinflation are worth 0.000002
[Music]
each a great arbitrage they would bleach
them and print right over them with a
new dollar value the security thread is
the next thing on the list get the
security thread with the right words on
it and stick it in between two layers of
thin money paper when someone lifts the
dollars to the lights they should be
able to see the security thread in
between
lastly you'll need the right serial
numbers for banknotes printed before
1996 a special letter is used before the
actual serial number find out what the
leather is according to the year you're
trying to replicate and use that
now that you have most of the equipment
ready you're gonna need a crew no matter
what the movies tell you counterfeiting
takes a lot of work you need an artist
to engrave the metal plates a forger to
make sure the engraving is accurate you
need a digital designer to blow up the
pictures of the notes for the forger and
artists to see you need delivery guys
lookouts printing supervisors and meals
the people who are gonna smuggle your
freshly printed money into the us you'll
also need to be on quality control if
one note looks wrong it could bring down
your entire operation so keep your eyes
open and don't accept any mistakes
once your team is assembled you can get
to the hardest parts actually printing
the money
[Music]
now that you're ready to go you can
start your printing operation there's a
lot of things to watch out for at the
step like checking print quality and
gradually starting to launder your fake
money in exchange for the real deal
watch our video on money laundering to
learn how
don't use the first notes you print
chances are they're not perfect and
today anything other than perfect is
unacceptable once you've printed enough
money to actually be worth something
it's time to find a buyer
[Music]
one of the safest ways to get rid of
counterfeit cash is to sell it and make
it someone else's problem if you printed
one million dollars prices will be
around 30 cents on the dollar that means
you can make a good clean 300 000 if you
sell to the right guy as long as your
buyer doesn't turn out to be an
undercover cop you're golden but if
you're not interested in making less
than half of what your dollars are worth
you could take it into your own hands
from your workshop smuggle the money
into the us using couriers people who
smuggle contraband once the money
reaches america where there's a lot more
confidence in the dollar you can use the
money to make small purchases in places
like clubs bars or shops where the staff
seems friendly and the lights are dim
pay with a hundred dollar bill and if
you bought something for ten dollars you
get ninety dollars back and real
reusable cash sure it's a lot more risky
but if you don't hit the same shopper
mall twice you should be fine
whatever way you choose if you've been
working for a while and a buyer suddenly
shows up out of nowhere ignore it almost
every great counterfeiter has been
caught selling to an undercover agent
once you've got your network running and
the literal money printer printing it's
time to sit back and enjoy the good life
[Music]
you